it was funny every Independence Day
every 4th of July on my channel I've
always been like I should review
Independence Day but it's always a movie
weekend in this movies coming out then
I'm like right now I just want to relax
so this is the time this is the year
folks ID for welcome to earth
[Music]
so Independence Day came out the summer
of 1996 this movie was a huge massive is
the word at the time this movie crushed
the trailer was really simple all it
really was was alien ships are coming
boom White House down we were all like
I'm watching that in fact this was the
movie when Phantom Menace was coming I
was like wait Independence Day happen I
know you got to get to this movie
theater early and buy your tickets in
advance because if you don't you just
get there late or on time which I guess
is late because you're stuck in the
front row like watching them you're like
that [ __ ] like I did with Independence
Day luckily I've watched Independence
Day three more times the theaters
they're just saying it taught me things
I mean at this time in the 90s this was
the height of just what everyone was
interested in extraterrestrials
encounters the hidden truth sightings
the truth is out there
yeah we all loved this movie but alright
so the plot is the plot that's what I
heard it's that the plot was the teaser
trailer aliens are coming they're
slowing down sir boom but also Will
Smith that's right The Fresh Prince of
bel-air this put Will Smith on the map
as an action star like a super star no
bad boys had already come out but when
you're a smooth ass cop in a cop action
movie that's one thing that's that's
that vibe when you're a Marine pilot
taking on aliens that's something
completely different you're a superstar
now if you pull this off and yeah he
totally did and the first act of this
movie is amazing set up the ships are
coming the fiery from coming through the
atmosphere and they break through that
music queues up it's all the right steps
taken to just build tension because I
mean we know how it's gonna go down we
saw the trailer I don't know how it's
gonna go down is actually people are
excited people are scared there's
obviously going to be an attack of it
how did I catch anyone off-guard in his
movie just based on where the alien
ships are located in America alone just
hovering there Washington DC the
country's leadership New York Wall
Street World Trade Center UN Hollywood
voice of people who hypnotize the
country into thinking the world operates
how they see it yet the hypnotists of
America point is does a coordinated
attack right there obviously gonna
happen I laughed my ass off in this
movie at that newscast it's like do not
shoot guns at the alien ships you may
ignite a galactic war which they would
have to do you'd have to say that
you know someone's going to good job all
right now let's send up a helicopter and
flashlights at the aliens which also
might set off a galactic war that's
actually in my head can and that's what
happened the whole countdown that Jeff
Goldblum finds no that's the countdown
to the surprise party that we weren't
supposed to know about all the aliens
like alright guys when it strikes zero
we all jump out of the ship and yell
surprise you're part of the Galactic
Council now we'll all meet up at the
Citadel it's gonna be great then we had
to [ __ ] it up by sending up a helicopter
that gave off the universal visual
signal for we the life-forms of this
planet declare war on you the visitors
anything's alike breaks our heart but I
guess we're at war with the humans now
serves us right for trying to be nice
regardless of how it sparked that
destruction that was second to none no
disaster or citywide destruction in the
history of any movie was as grand as
this this was crazy and didn't stop it
was like a slow peel of a band-aid also
this was the first movie I was in where
people actively cheered at things and
Will Smith came on-screen everyone
cheered Will Smith cracked a joke and
talked some [ __ ]
people cheered when the dog jumped and
just missed the fiery blast people
cheered no one cheered for anyone else
surviving except the dog because they
know the math you remember math true
that's universal right right when this
movie started out there was actually
more humor than I initially thought
there would be which works it completely
works because if it didn't have that
humor the only element of humor was Will
Smith it might have felt out of place
now Will Smith works in this movie and
also brings that Will Smith flare to the
character and he just injects it in
every scene he's in and I mean long
story short you can't have this movie
take yourself too seriously it's about
aliens who come to earth and they blow
us up and then we blow them up also
recycle it is like humor action horror
movie segment which is always rough when
Bill Pullman is all talking to the alien
there's a strobe light effect so it
always hurts my eye I'm not even gonna
play the clip here because it's like I
don't want to hurt your eyes you'd like
if I show that scene in here I feel like
I have to give some seizure disclaimer
like hey there's flashing images in this
review beware if you really look at it
Jeff Goldblum's character David I'm
gonna say he's a psycho but you know
projecting his insecurities
he's still wearing his wedding ring
after three years being divorced from
his now ex-wife he punched a guy
thinking she was cheating on him with
this other guy when she wasn't who ends
up given one of the greatest movie
speeches of all time I'm just saying
today we celebrate our Independence Day
[Music]
he didn't support her and her career
ambitions he's like no no he being a
cable guy that's enough it should be
enough for you too it's just kind of
weird this movie has a couple things
like that rose like I guess yeah this
90s captain Steven Hiller Will Smith's
characters dating a stripper is like oh
you'll never get to fly the space
shuttle if you're marrying a stripper
like what the [ __ ] does that [ __ ] matter
I don't know but back then it was
completely logical like yeah yeah he'll
never get to fly that times change
perspective change perception changes
and if we're talking about times
changing this movie is all about the
left and the right coming together to
save humanity that's right the Go Green
or go home super leftist and the guns
out right-wingers come together to save
humanity the 90s my friends anything
David Jeff Goldblum's character his dad
has a whole monologue like ah I don't
give me unprepared you've known about
this for awhile you did nothing what
would doing something look like I'm just
saying I'm just saying
now tinfoil hat what does he know but
the setup is great when they kick our
ass it's epic when we kick their ass
it's exciting the middle part starts to
reach that alright we need to fill it in
but I remember watching the movie like
oh yeah it can't just be destruction all
the time is what's the movie actually
about it's also two and a half hours
long it's gonna fill it in with
something in the hitch the movie trying
to move everyone together so we can make
our big last stand the whole Randy Quaid
thing and his family drags on for so
long and then it's finally relevant at
the end so I guess there's payoff there
but that's where it's I'm like wow this
is dragons in the area 51 think this
movie's actually what got me so like I
don't want spoilers it got me so spoiler
conscious because I've watched this
thing on Fox was like I went to penance
day and I was like I'm not like they're
gonna spoil the movie or anything and in
this special on TV before the movie came
out interviews with brent Spiner and
they talked about area 51 and I was like
Woods is what I didn't know they're
going to area 51 for like a whole
segment of the movie was spoiled for me
so I knew it was coming before it
actually happened regardless the second
act is where it starts having a lull and
then the third act is when you have to
take all the leaps because it's a fire
is is a computer virus that's how the
world gets saved Jeff Goldblum uploads a
computer virus into the mothership and
it filters
down to the other ships and then that's
how we get to take them out because the
shields they deactivate that was the
thing or if you start thinking about it
even back then you're like I just can't
I can't do that I can't deconstruct the
movie I'm just supposed to enjoy the
mayhem as it's happening
you're telling me Microsoft and Apple
products are less compatible than a PC
and alien tech I mean it is Apple were
talking about it they lock that [ __ ]
down
also Will Smith gets to fly this ship
that looks like it's built for humans I
mean when he one punch
alright that's badass by the way it just
bunches this alien in its biomechanical
suit face and knocks the alien out with
the punch by punching its suit face not
his actual face still knocks it out I
mean the one punch machine gun Mickey
from snatch couldn't have pulled that
[ __ ] off but yeah Fresh Prince of
bel-air will [ __ ] you alien but still
I'm glad he gets to go up into space cuz
it's been his dream but you look at that
cockpit and you're like yeah that wasn't
made for aliens so it imagine like the
steering device would be these holes
that like three people that to put their
hands in and steer the thing as logical
is of supervirus getting uploaded to the
main computer you got it man you gotta
take leaps in this last act but this is
an epic movie it was an instant classic
it crushed in the box-office and now
it's like every fourth of July I think
of it I think of it I have to watch it
thus I do it's usually on TV somehow in
some capacity or some streaming service
has it or you own three different copies
of it because let's just be real it's
not flawless sure but some of those
visual effects like this was the first
movie I was like wait you're telling me
the Jets aren't real what are you
talking about it like it was CGI its
destruction it's mayhem some of the
pacing starts slowing down in the second
act
but regardless if you can just sit back
and enjoy this movie you'll enjoy the
cast the characters the humor the funds
put it on enjoy your barbecue it's a
movie that knows what it is it owns it
and that's all I can ask for because
it's worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray actually now I'm thinking about
the initial scenes even kind of
brilliant you see the footprints on the
moon of the first people who walked on
the moon and those footprints just get
shaken away they just get erased the
footprints of humanity
at the height of their exploration and
imagination just erased by these aliens
it's just really fitting and that's the
new ones I love is think about these 90s
movies you know they were fun they were
cheese but they had nuance and as the
4th of July Independence Day is upon us
please be safe out there just don't do
anything stupid safety first in all
forms firstly when dependents stay have
you seen it what did you think about it
I don't know a lot people haven't seen
this movie but it's possible but
whatever you think of it comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]